Devil May Cry 5 isn't shy about being a
pure celebration of the series's past
while it has plenty of new ideas this
latest sequel is laced with entertaining
callbacks that are sure to bring a smile
to your face in addition there's a
surprising amount of extended universe
lore acknowledged in DMC 5 that even
hardcore fans might not recognize for
your entertainment and general amusement
we've compiled the most noteworthy
Easter eggs and references in DMC 5 be
wary there are some lights or others
ahead anyway let's get on to it shall we
the city of Redgrave is a nod to Tony
Redgrave which is Dante's alias in the
anime and early light novels in a note
in the gallery menu this element is
reintroduced into the Canon
explaining that Dante took on the name
since Redgrave City is his hometown the
name Tony Redgrave itself is a nod to
Capcom's past as it's Dante's original
name back when dmc1 was being developed
as Resident Evil 4
[Music]
throughout the story Nikko continually
brings up Nell Goldstein her grandmother
and legendary gunsmith my grandmother
was called the 45 caliber virtuoso
legendary goes me I hope to be like her
someday
an artist known as the 45 caliber
virtuoso Nell originates from a Devil
May Cry light novel she and Dante who
went by Tony at the time are established
in the book as close friends the
fledgling demon hunter would often stop
by Nell shop to buy new guns as well as
sell any spares he picked up but during
his jabs Dante would often break his
pistols so Nell decided to craft for him
the indestructible dual pistols a beanie
and ivory to solve this persistent
annoyance after Devil May Cry threes
released details in that game's story
ended up contradicting the events of
that novel and as a result were removed
from the Canon however JD Morrison's
letters to Nero Indy mc5 end up bringing
a lot of the novel's elements back into
the Canon including Nell goldstein
speaking of JD Morrison he originates
from Delhi May Cry the animated series a
small 12-episode anime that ran back in
2007 unlike the novel the anime is canon
taking place after dmc1 and introducing
Morrison as Dante's agent who brings him
job requests
don't forget I'm counting on you though
the Morrison in the show features a
completely different design from the
game another character introduced in the
anime is patty Lowell a young girl that
ends up in Dantes care and lives in the
Devil May Cry shop for a time she makes
a voiced appearance in DMC 5 calling up
Dante to invite him to her 18th birthday
party
[Music]
how does it feel to be rescuing the guy
that killed your father
well he abandoned my mother and I left
us for dead Nico's father is mentioned a
few times throughout the mc5 but it's
never explicitly stated who he is
but if you research the gallery enough
you can find several notes pointing to
his identity profile that Nikko wrote up
on dark nights Sparta mentions that her
father was from Fortuna which is the
primary setting of DMC for in addition
the Red Queen weapon report states that
Nico's father has designed the blade if
there's anyone from previous games who
most fits the bill based on these clues
it's Agnes the smarmy researched
obsessed scientist from DMC for soon
this lines up with details confirmed
about Nico's father early on who was
said to be killed by Dante and given
Nico's general disdain for her father it
makes the most sense that it's Agnes
[Music]
the Cavalier is likely a callback to the
series's love of inserting motorcycles
into action scenes specifically in dmc1
and dmc3 this crazy Chainsaw motorcycle
is earned after defeating Cavalier
Angelo which is the boss that Trish was
trapped inside getting the Cavalier
after this fight in particular is
fitting given Trish's association with
motorcycles she did crash into Dante's
office with one in dmc1 after all
[Music]
if you didn't recognize them already
these familiars shadow Griffin and
nightmare are direct nods to dmc1 bosses
of the same names in fact many of their
attacks and animations are lifted
straight from those bosses for example
shadows bayonet attack is very similar
to the attack that it's dmc1 counterpart
opens up its boss fight with you'll even
notice later on that much of mission 18
features several call backs of each
familiars dmc1 counterpart including the
return of boss themes and some dialogue
referencing events on Malay Island one
more round it's like a back of Malay
Island the punchline double breaker has
an added function that allows you to
ride it like a skateboard which is
incredibly satisfying to use this isn't
the first time a DMC protagonist has
ridden the brachot though the second
mission cutscene in DMC 3 features Dante
doing the same act of the Cerberus boss
fight
[Music]
the ability to ride the punch line in
this manner is likely a reference to
that over-the-top scene
the devil arm dr. Faust is named after
the Faust the shrouded hat-wearing demon
from DMC for when you acquire the weapon
from Nikko you witness quite a hilarious
fourth wall breaking scene of Dante
dancing like Michael Jackson as strobe
lights flicker and fireworks go off in
the background this scene is likely an
ode to DMC for Dante's ridiculous
shenanigans from his post boss fight
cutscene
Dante has a taunt that pays homage to
the sexual innuendo laced monologue he
delivers after defeating burial in DMC
poor it generally triggers when you
achieve an s-rank you'll know when
you've done it when he throws a rose and
says and that wraps up all the Easter
eggs and references we got but were
there any that you noticed that we
didn't mention here let us know in the
comments anyway go play more Devil May
Cry 5 thanks for watching
[Music]